diese neue technologie könnte wirklich
eine revolution sein forschungsteam vom
renommierten massachusetts institute of
technology mit hat jetzt eine neue
technik entwickelt mit der sich
schaltung oder kleine sensoren ihren
strom quasi aus der luft holen könnten
konkret geht es um eine art antenne die
ausweich funkwellen eine autonome
stromversorgung ermöglicht können wir
demnächst smartphone und co also einfach
über das wlan aufladen klicks und
science fiction gibt es täglich
faszinierende wissenschafts videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann und nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen inzwischen ist es leichter
ein wlan netz zu finden als eine
steckdose wie gehen ja wäre es denn wenn
die elektromagnetischen wellen des wlan
netzwerkes nicht nur zur
datenübertragung nutzbar werden sondern
gleichzeitig unsere geräte wie handy
oder tablet auch mit strom versorgen
würden ganz nach dem motto tschüs
ladekabel genau solch eine technik hat
jetzt ein internationales forschungsteam
entwickelt zumindest in form eines
prototypen konkret geht es um eine so
genannte reck turner im englischen reckt
iv empfänger was so viel heißt wie
gleich richtende antenne in der
fachsprache ist damit eine schaltung
anordnung gemeint die hochfrequente
elektromagnetische wellen empfangen und
diese dann in eine gleichspannung
umwandeln kann vielleicht klingelt es an
dieser stelle bei denjenigen die sich
noch an die sogenannten kristall radios
erinnern die auf einem ähnlichen prinzip
basieren das ist eine ganze weile her
diese speziellen radiogeräte aus den
anfängen des rundfunks bestanden aus nur
sehr wenigen bauteilen und basierten auf
einer einfachen technik sie wandelten
nämlich elektromagnetische schwingungen
von radiowellen in ein hörbares signal
um und zwar über einen gleich richter
übrigens bei häusern damals in der nähe
sich von funkmasten befanden da haben
teilweise die ofenrohre das übernommen
und haben die funkwellen wirklich
transferiert in hörbare signale und man
konnte am ofenrohr lauschen und das
radiosignal hören also das ist gar nicht
so kompliziert sie kamen also ohne
eigene stromversorgung aus unter der
voraussetzung dass die sender stark
genug waren theoretisch gesehen könnte
man auch heutzutage
wellen von mobilfunk- oder weicher
sendern anzapfen
davon gibt es reichlich doch mangelte es
bisher an geeigneten materialien
ofenrohr verhindern ich die auch für
tragbare elektronische geräte eingesetzt
werden könnten eine solche drahtlose
form der energieübertragung wird ja auch
schon bei rfid chips genutzt doch auch
hier sind diese gleich richtenden
antennen aus dickem und und flexiblem
material das ist bei der neu
entwickelten reck turner des mtv
forschungsteams anders die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben für den bau ihres prototypen das
hochleistungs material namens the danish
die sulfit mos2 genutzt es entsteht bei
der reaktion von schwefel mit molle den
oxid und fungiert als elektronen leiter
wohl einer der dünnsten halbleiter
weltweit der sich schichtweise
herstellen lässt und das ist wirklich
krass die so konstruierte antenne ist
nur noch drei atom mutig und somit
unglaublich flexibel zu kreieren kann
sie auch großflächig produziert werden
so wandelt direkt an das wechselstrom
signal der wlan netzwerke in eine
gleichspannung um und genau diese ist in
der lage elektronische schaltung zu
betreiben oder batterien aufzuladen
die neu entwickelte reck tanner kann mit
wifi signale von etwa 150 mikrowatt
umgehen das ist eine durchaus typische
leistung und kann daraus eine leistung
von etwa 40 mikrowatt erzeugen damit
kann zwar kein tablet am laufen gehalten
werden doch die beleuchtung eines
gewöhnlichen handydisplays gelingt damit
das forschungsteam selbst setzt große
hoffnung in diese technologie denn sie
könnte für allerhand anwendungen
spannend sein beispielsweise in der
medizinischen diagnostik in der mini
geräte daten aus dem körperinneren der
patienten funken im vergleich zu
batterien die in diesem zusammenhang ein
gesundheitliches risiko darstellen würde
eine solche dünne elektronik kaum
volumen darstellen aber auch bauwerke
können in regionen die erdbeben
gefährdet sind durch zahlreiche sensoren
in ihrer stabilität überwacht werden
dazu thomas palacios einer der
beteiligten forscher
damit lässt sich eine breite palette an
sensoren für die umweltüberwachung oder
die chemische und biologische sensorik
entwerfen die auf der basis von nur
einem mikrowatt arbeiten oder sie
speichern den strom in einer batterie
die sie später nutzen können fest steht
diese idee signale aus der luft zur
stromgewinnung zu nutzen ist sich neu
auch andere forschungsteams tüfteln an
der umsetzung beispielsweise hat apple
im frühling 2017 patent für eine
technologie angemeldet die den router
als ladestation und wifi als
energiequelle nutzt da haben wir also
noch eine menge zu erwarten und auch in
diesem bereich machen eben neue
werkstoffe dinge möglich die früher
unmöglich erschien und wer weiß
vielleicht könnte die energie aus
wlan-netzwerken demnächst handys
zumindest in ausgeschaltetem zustand
langsam laden allein das wäre ein
riesiger fortschritt unsichtbar durch
zeit löcher geht das auf dieses video
hier klicken wenn er diese frage von
neugier zone beantwortet haben wollt
auch ein extrem spannendes video
abonnieren nicht vergessen auch die
neugier zone natürlich und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran